Bilimsel yöntem ve çalışma basamaklarına
baktığınız zaman aslında standardı tam
olarak oturmuş bir konu değil. Sonuçta
bilimden bahsediyoruz. Bunun içerisinde
fen bilimleri var, sosyal bilimler var,
tıp bilimleri var ve bir sürü aslında
bilimsel alt dallar var. Dolayısıyla bir
genel ifade, genel çerçeve kullanacağız.
İşte problemi saptamak, verileri
toplamak, veri, kayıt altına alınmış
bilgilerimiz. Hipotez oluşturmak,
problemi çözmek için geçici çözüm yolu
sunuyorsunuz. Hipoteze dayalı tahmin
yapmak. Genelde burada bir sıralama
sorusu sorulur. İşte hipotez mi önce
kurulur yoksa tahmin mi önce yapılır?
Basit bir mantık. Hipoteze dayalı
tahmin. Demek ki tahmin hipotezden sonra
deney tasarlayacaksınız. Kontrollü deney
yapacaksınız. Birazdan söyleyeceğim.
Kontrollü deney değişkenlerden sadece
bir tanesi değiştirilerek yapılır.
Sonuçta bir kontrol grubu kurmam lazım
ve o kontrol grubunun yanına değişkenin
birini değiştirerek örnekler koymam
lazım. Mesela işte ışık rengini
değiştireceksin bitkinin gelişimi için.
Gidip de o bitkilere verdiğin su
miktarını değiştiremezsin. Çünkü
bitkinin gelişimi üzerine etki eden
faktörleri anlayamazsın. Şimdi ışığı da
değiştirdim, suyu da değiştirdim. Kime
göre gelişti o zaman? ya ışığı
değiştireceksin ya suyu değiştireceksin
ve ona göre deney yapacaksın gibi. Peki
hocam sonrasında deneylerden sonra sen
sonuçları değerlendireceksin ve bu
sonuçlar tutarlı sonuçlarsa hipotezi
destekliyorsa bunlar artık gerçek
olacak. Desteklemiyorsa o zaman hipotezi
değiştireceksin gibi bir kurgumuz var
arkadaşlar. Tekrar edelim. Gözlem
yaptım. Veri topladım. Problemi tespit
ettim. Çözüm yolu sunuyorum. Hipotez
oluşturuyorum. Hipoteze dayalı tahmin
yapıyorum. Kontrollü deneylerle hipotezi
sınıyorum. Sonuçları değerlendiriyorum.
Eğer hipotezi desteklemiyor ise hipotez
gözden geçirilip yeni bir hipotez
kurulacak. Hipotez destekleniyorsa
deneyler tekrarlanır. Sonuçlar başka
araştırmacılar tarafından doğrulanır ve
gerçek haline gelir. Şimdi arkadaşlar
bakın şöyle bir ifade yok. İşte ben
hipotezi aldım, doğruladım. Bu gitti
teori oldu.
Yani teori bir tane hipotezle mi ortaya
konuluyor? Arkadaşlar teoriyi şöyle
düşünmeniz lazım. Altında onlarca
yüzlerce hipotez tarafından desteklenen
görüşlerdir. Artık onlar bilimsel
kabullerdir. Ve şöyle bir ifade de yok
arkadaşlar. Teori kanuna dönüşmez. Yani
hocam işte teoriler zayıftır aslında.
Biraz daha kanıt bulsaydık kanun olurdu.
Böyle cümleler kurmayın arkadaşlar.
Tamam mı? Bu cümleler bilimsel değil.
Bir tane hipotez teoriye kanuna
dönüşmez. Çünkü teoriler, kanunlar
yüzlerce hipotezden beslenir. Ya da
teori kanuna dönüşmez. Kanun teoriden
güçlü bir ifade değildir. Bunlar farklı
bilimsel kavramlardır. Lütfen bunlara
dikkat edin. Tamam mı? Bunlar bariz
yanlış cümleler çünkü. Peki gel burada
biraz daha konuşalım. Problemi saptadın.
Ne yapacaksın? Gözlemler yapacaksın
değil mi? İki çeşit gözlem var.
Bunlardan bir tanesi nitel, diğeri
nicel. Nicel'de sayısal ifadeler.
Nitelde biraz daha böyle 5 duy organ.
İşte bu daha büyük, bu daha küçük. Ama
nicel yaptığın zaman işte bu 25 cm, bu
30 cm, bu 30 s, bu 40 s gibi
matematiksel ifadeler vereceksin. Yani
senin keyfine bağlı olmayacak. Verileri
toplayacaksın ve bakın ne dedim az önce.
veriler kayıt altına alınmış
bilgilerimiz arkadaşlar. Hipotezi
oluşturacaksın. Hipotez nedir? Hipotez
problem için ileri sürülmüş geçici
çözümlerdir. Ve iyi bir hipotezin
özelliği ne olmalı? Aslında burada
gördüğün şeylere bak. Hipotez bir kere
sonrasında kontrollü deneylerle
sınanabilmeli. Üzerinden tahminler
oluşturulmalı. Eldeki verilere uygun
olmalı. Sonrasında değiştirilebilir
olmalı. Aslında burada tabloda gördüğüm
şeyler hipotezin özellikleri. Bak şimdi
tahmin verilere uygun, akla mantığa
uygun. Deney gözlemle denenebilir,
kontrolü deney. Yeni tahminlere yol
açabilir. Tahmini sen hipotezden sonra
yapıyorsun. Eğer sonuç uyuşmazsa
değiştirilebilir gibi aslında o tabloyu
buna uygulayabilirsin.
Dikkat et. Hipoteze dayalı tahmin
yapılır dedim. İşte klasik soru
kalıpları var. Eğer nokta nokta ise
nokta nokta başka hangi doğruların
olabileceği hakkında tahminler yapılır
şeklinde bir cümle kurmuşum arkadaşlar.
Ve kontrollü deneylerde değişkenlerden
biri hariç diğerleri sabit tutulur. Yani
değişkenlerden bir tanesini
değiştireceksin. Diğerlerini sabit
tutacaksın. Son iki kavram var burada.
Deneyde değişken olan faktör nedir?
bağımsız değişkendir. Ortamda sabit
değerde bulunanlara sabit değişken
denir. Bir de sizin yaptığınız işin
sonucuna bağlı olarak ortaya çıkan
bağımlı değişkendir. Bak
çok basit bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Diyeceğim ki hocam benim elimde bir tane
bitki var. Şu şekilde bir kontrolü deney
yapıyorum. Tamam güzel. Bu kontrol grubu
olsun. Şunlar da deney grubu olsun.
Bak çok basit bir şey. Bunu bilim insanı
olduğunuz zaman, olmak isteyenler için
söylüyorum. Her gün zaten
uygulayacağınız yöntemlerden bir tanesi.
Şimdi sizin kontrol grubunuz ve deney
grubunuz var. Doğru mu? Diyelim ki siz
deney ortamında gittiniz ve buraya yeşil
ışık gönderdiniz. Şuraya da arkadaşlar
kırmızı ışık gönderdiniz. Burada
bağımsız değişken nedir? etkisi
araştırılan kişidir. Bağımsız değişken
yani ışığın rengidir bağımsız değişken.
Dalga boyu değil mi? Bunun sonucu ise
ışığın rengine bağlı olacağı için
bağımlı değişken olacak. Lütfen öyle
gözünüzde büyütmeyin. Kompleks haline
getirmeyin. Bakın 10 tane fasulye tohumu
var. Özdeş saksı sabit değişken yani
özdeşlik var. Bakın bağımsız değişkenle
su. Neden? Çünkü sen birini sulamışsın
birini sulamamışsın. O zaman etkisi
araştırılan kişi suyun kendisi ise o
bağımsız değişkendir. Deney grubu,
kontrol grubu. Bakın bağımlı değişken
filizlenen tohum oranıdır. Çünkü bir
sonuçtur o. Bir şeye bağlı olarak
gelişen durumdur dedim ve burayı da
arkadaşlar bitirmiş oldum. baktığınız
zaman aslında bilimsel yöntem ve bu tarz
çalışmalar işte fizikte, kimyada da soru
olarak karşınıza çıkabilir ama bir ÖSYM
sorusu vardı aslında. Sadece seçeneklere
bile bakılarak yapılabilirdi. Şöyle bir
öğrenci grubu var. Patatest deney
yapıyorlar ve bayağı bir anlatmış. Yarım
sayfa anlatmış. Ama bazı öğrencilerim
dedi ki hocam çok uzun sürdü. Çok
üzüldük. O soruyu yetiştiremedik. Ben de
şöyle bir şey söylemiştim kendilerine.
Bir deney, bir öğrenci grubu bir okulda
patatesle deney yapıyorlar. Sizce
patatesle yapılan deneyin sonucu bir
teori olabilir mi? Bir anda böyle bir
sessizlik. Arkadaşlar tekrar söylüyorum.
Bir şeyin teori olabilmesi için yüzlerce
hipotez ortaya atılması lazım. Gitmiş
patatesi folyoya koymuş. Çimlenme
oranına bakmış. Teori olur mu bu? Orada
hipotezler olabilir. Orada deney
kontrolü deney yapılmış olabilir. Orada
bir sonuç oluşturulmuş olunabilir. Orada
veri toplanmış olunabilir. Ama kanun ya
da teori oradan çıkmaz arkadaşlar.
Birazcık uyanık olacağız. ÖSYM bu tarz
soruları sormayı seviyor. Çok uzatıyor
böyle. Ama aslında hızlı pratik
zekamızla soruyu doğru çözebiliriz.
Evet. Bir mola sonrasında checkpoint.